الطلاق مشاهدينا عبر وسائل التكنولوجيا
بات من الامور المستحدثه ربما اخرها كان
عن طريق الانستقرام لاعب كره القدم
التونسي عمار الجمل اعلن الطلاق من زوجته
عبر خاصيه الاستوري في انستجرام ليشعل
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ووسائل الاعلام
لسبب الطلاق بس هو يعني اسوا طريقه لا
يعني الاعلان وامراه تعرف انه هي طلقت
يعني عن طريق السوشيال ميديا على كل حال
زوجه البراجر المعروفه اروى لا تجيد الطبخ
وشؤون المنزل ولا تحترم وجباتها الزوجيه
بحسب طبعا عمار زوجها وجوه معروفه على
السوشيال ميديا انتقدت تصرف اللاعب بشده
مطالبين اياه بصون العشره على الاقل
العشره معتبرين تصرفات اهانه كبيره لزوجته
عمار الجمل وجه منتقديه بانه لا يصغي الى
الدروس خاصه الذين يعتبرهم فاشلين في
حياتهم الزوجيه قال ايضا في اشاره لزوجه
البلوجر بان من ينشر حياه الخاصه باستمرار
على السوشيال ميديا ولا يظهر يظهر الا
الجانب الايجابي عليه ان يتحمل
بدوره الجانب السلبي لهذه الحياه ويتوقف
عن التزييف كن شفافا هذا اللي يقوله هو هو
كمان عم يستعمل السوشيال ميديا يعني وينشر
ايضا امور خاصه عن طريق السوشيال ميديا بس
على كل حال الله في خلقه شؤون
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات